Okay, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P uh, we received a voicemail.
That is interesting.
It's about veterans.
And the left.
I disagree with the premise of the voicemail,
but let's listen to it first and then I'll
tell you what I think.
Hey David, this is Shane from Mountain SRE,
uh, tried to get you on the call line and
didn't, but I wanted to ask you this question
cause I think it means a lot.
Um, we'll the last number meaningfully accept
veterans and their families under the big
tent.
I'd asked you to consider at least for the
sake of argument that veterans are among the
most class conscious and class organized groups
in this country.
Uh, look at team Rubicon team red, white and
blue that do charity work and disaster prevention.
Um, and all of the organizations that support
veterans, uh, this accepting of, uh, military
veterans under the big left tent would also
help in taking the corporate dems and the
Corporate Republicans, uh, ability to wrap
themselves in the flag.
You know, as a vet, I want to be part of the
solution for my country, not part of the problem.
And I definitely feel like the direction that
you represent and other people are representing
now are part of the solution, not part of
the problem.
How do we clear the barrier?
Can we, I'd asked you to consider the bonus
march and spent the, there's, where's the
racquet?
Thank you very much for your time.
Listen, I disagree with the premise.
Okay.
I agree that the right has won the propaganda
war around supporting the troops, but the
left does accept veterans.
The left is, listen, it's not patriotic to
say, let's send our troops all over the place,
uh, to spread democracy or whatever.
That's not, that's not patriotic.
And it's not, uh, supporting the veterans
when the left says we really should be considering
use of the, of the military as our last resort.
We shouldn't use the military for political
fights.
We shouldn't use the military in ways that
we are putting them in harm's way for the
personal priorities of whoever's in the White
House that is supporting the troops.
When we say, Hey, the veterans are coming
back and they're not getting the care that
they need.
And there's PTSD and these and there's other
things and we've got to fund that properly.
That's patriotic, that supports the veterans,
that supports the troops.
When Trump says there's lots of veterans who
just aren't strong enough so they have PTSD,
right?
That does not support the troops, that does
not support veterans.
So I reject wholeheartedly the idea that veterans
and their families are not accepted by the
left.
It's that the right has, and it may even have
infected this color, the right has so successfully
run the propaganda war around the troops that
you end up getting calls like this where someone
says, hey, it would be really great if the
left accepted veterans.
What exactly are you talking about when you
say that?
Because I consider my views on troops and
veterans of the most up pro troop and pro
veteran views one can have.
They just aren't use our troops for political
gain around the world, uh, indefinitely increase
funding to unnecessarily cartoonish levels
to endlessly buy and replace more and more
weapons that will never be used and that we
don't need.
That doesn't seem to support the troops.
That doesn't seem to support veterans.
I'm actually for supporting the troops and
veterans in the ways that I would prioritize,
number one, keeping them safe and number two,
keeping them healthy and number three, uh,
jobs, programs and reintegration into society
after serving overseas, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera.
So give me a break.
The left has no problem with veterans, but
we have unfortunately lost the propaganda
war in great part to messaging from the right
around support the troops.
Sad, very, very sad.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
yet another threat to the affordable care
act.
I will also talk about Netflix making an announcement
that they are going to try to pair down in
Netflix original programming, the amount of
smoking of cigarettes that takes place because
of complaints that at this point in time we
should really stop quote, glorifying smoking
by having lead characters and others smoked
cigarettes in shows.
Um, very interesting topic which I want to
get into on the bonus show.
And lastly, nearly a quarter of Americans
now say they do not believe they will ever
retire according to a new poll.
We will talk about the details of that as
well as the economic implications and the
socio cultural implications.
Get access to the bonus show instantly by
becoming a member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomingapatronatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpacman.com
[inaudible].